It perhaps isn't clear from the JPEG video
when JPEG isn't a good idea.
I mean, a lot of people say "oh, you should never use JPEG for scientific images" or something like that
because it's totally lossy compression, you're going to lose those equality.
And that is true
but it's also not in a sense that you're applying its lossy compression over very very small image blocks.
So you won't get coherence between one block and the next
but it'll look pretty good and for most imaging that's okay.
Obviously lots of people swear by shooting in raw, and you know, good luck to them.
JPEG uses up a lot less space, and so for most practical purposes a JPEG image is fine.
One time where JPEG images are not fine is text.
Most people will have spotted JPEG artefacts, that is, speckly bits of image around text
and maybe not quite understood why that's there apart from it's just a side effect of JPEG compression.
Well specifically, it's a side effect of JPEG compression on text
because text violates our assumptions that
high frequency information doesn't contribute a lot to the image.
So this is a small 8x8 image that I've come up with to illustrate its purpose.
So this is, in a sense, text. This is the Computerphile C with its little triangular brackets.
It's 8x8, so it's not the highest resolution, but it serves our purpose quite well.
One thing that this image has that our last image of the flower didn't have is sharp changes in intensity.
So this C has a sharp step down into the background
and that is not something that JPEG handles very well at all.
If we look at the encoded luminosity block of this
we get this.
So this is our C represented as just 0 to 255 luminosity values.
So these are our background ones of about 48.
This is our C here
and our brackets here
Each of these represents the greyscale intensity of that corresponding pixel in our 8x8 image.
Now if we were encoding this in JPEG, what we would then do is we would shift all these
and we would calculate our DCT coefficients.
And then we would get rid of the high frequency ones and we would encode them.
And in doing so, we massively compress the image at what we assume to be a pretty reasonable quality.
But that isn't true in this case.
If we look at the DCT coefficients
you can see that our assumption that the big ones are always in the top left
so that the low frequency contributes more to the image
is hugely violated.
This particular coefficient, for example, only contributes 0.8.
That was, I think, a value of 200 or something in our last video.
Down here we have big, big coefficients.  30, 67.5, 53, -53.
All in these really high frequency cosine waves.
So if we look at our logo coefficients next to our DCT
We can see that what we've essentially got is a loss of this one here, so that's this one.
So this C has a lot of this particularly contributable one
which you can kind of see because there is a kind of C shape in it.
And so, it's hard perhaps to grasp the exact contribution that this will have
because these coefficients are essentially arbitrary numbers
But the point is that this image is the addition of lots of these high frequency sections
and a lot less of these low frequency ones.
So when we do our standard quantization, we're going to divide all of these numbers by huge amounts
and set most of them to 0
and that's going to be a big problem, because when we then recreate the image on the other side
we're going to find that what was vital in creating this image is now gone and we're not going to get it back.
And in fact that's exactly what you do see. So if we show the actual output here
we can see that our C is kind of visible
but is being completely dwarfed by all this random noise that's been added
to the edge of our text. And this is exactly what happens in normal
compression of text using JPEGs.  Essentially we assume
just like in normal nature photographs
that we can get rid of the high frequency information
and we couldn't do that.  That was a bad
idea. And so we've got all this stuff that
we shouldn't have.
If we look at the block when compared to the
original we can see that this value is 48.  It's now 66.
So a lot of these values have changed by
quite a large amount.  In our last video
I think the standard error between
the old and the new were something like 3.
On average they changed about 3, up or
down.  This is about 11.
It's over triple the amount of sort of average error that we're getting in our pixels.
And because it's text, we can see that very clearly in the output image.
So, the solution to this, really, is not to use JPEG when you've got a huge amount of text
bearing in mind that I shrank that C down to fit into one 8x8 block.
In actual fact you would have, if you had like, a sign
you would find that a letter took up a huge amount of the image
and so maybe you are only compressing one small edge of it and it won't look so bad.
But certainly, if you're compressing your
JPEG with text in it at 50 percent
or lower quality you're going to start
to see JPEG artifacts where
because these higher frequencies have been removed, you get kind of speckles
where they would have dulled that down.  You might have seen it actually, if you load up a poorly
compressed text document
that when you zoom in it doesn't scale well and
that's why
e-readers won't use something like this, they'll try and render the text sort of
from source, as it were, and that way they don't have any of these problems.
The interesting thing is that once this damage is done
it doesn't make it worse to keep re-encoding it, because the coefficients for this are now
all 0, because we set them to 0.  If we re-encoded this as a JPEG, it's not
going to get progressively worse unless
we change the quality settings.
It's actually just going to stay this bad.  So essentially, this is a
bad JPEGable version of this, which you should stick to if you want to keep using JPEG.  But otherwise, avoid it.
...absolutely useless in almost any other domain.  If you put a chess AI in a Google self-driving car
not only can it not drive the car, it doesn't have the concept, it doesn't know what a car is...